BRAD ABRAMS: Good afternoon, and
thank you for coming back
from lunch.
You know, whenever I speak at a
big conference like this, I
always ask them to put me
right after lunch, when
everybody's a little bit tired,
because what I find is
the people that come to the
session right after lunch are
the most interesting, engaged,
smartest, best-looking
audiences, don't you think?
I think so.
So we're really excited
about this talk.
Ido and I are going to go
through how to use HTML5 and
App Engine to build modern
web applications.
So I'm Brad Abrams, and I'm a
product manager on the cloud
platform team.
IDO GREEN: And I'm Ido Green,
and I'm a developer advocate
for Chrome.
BRAD ABRAMS: So Ido, if we're
going to talk about HTML5 and
App Engine and building great
modern web apps, maybe we
should define for the audience
what a modern
web app really is.
IDO GREEN: Absolutely.
So the web is changing so
quickly that it's really hard
to keep up with all the new
capabilities and rich APIs
that we're getting every
six weeks, actually.
Things that we weren't able to
do, like, 6 or 12 months ago,
we're now able to
do on the web.
And we saw in the keynote some
really, really impressive
demos for that.
So when we come to define web
apps, it's actually quite
hard, because we see lots of
fragmentation on the web.
But however, there's a few
things that we've found that
are quite common in all of the
great web apps that are out
there today.
One, and foremost, the first
goal for all those web apps is
to be as easy as possible
for the user to use.
They want to let the user
achieve their goals with as
much efficiency as possible.
Some of them are built in
offline first methodology.
And what that means is that
you're thinking from the
ground up how the app will look
like and how the app will
react when there's no
connection, and then building
on top of it.
So it's not like any other edit
feature that you want to
add to an existing app.
It's more of, let's think how
this app will work when
there's no connection, and
build on top of it.
When we're moving more and more
logic to the client side,
we're dealing with more code.
And that's--
I'm sure some of you
are smiling--
causing lots of spaghetti
code.
And I think that's one of the
main reasons why we see a huge
movement and flourishing in MVC,
or actually I should say
MV*, because we have MVP and
VVM, and lots of others, that
are basically coming to make a
clear separation between our
data models and our UI, and
make our code much more
readable and maintainable.
The last part is that we want
those web apps to feel as
native as possible, and we have
today with HTML5 all the
great APIs to do drag and drop
transition, 3D, and others.
We want to reach 60
frames per second.
Why?
Because above it, the
eye couldn't tell.
And we want to save some CPU
cycles, and make ourselves,
our users, and Al Gore happy.
So those two parts are extremely
important when
you're thinking about
your great web app.
Here is a great example,
Hipmunk.
They are basically letting you
do one thing and one thing
only, find the best flight
for your needs.
You could see how immersive it
is, how functional it is, and
if you're setting new
parameters, or you just want
to start a new search, you don't
need to shift focus.
You are all in that app.
Another great app that I had the
pleasure to work with is
My Chrome Theme.
It's basically letting you
create your own personal
Chrome theme and share with
friends and family, and I
highly encourage you
to check it out.
It's using all the best
technology, CSS3 and HTML5 in
order to achieve this goal.
When we're coming to speak about
client-side architecture
and technology, there's
a huge amount of
different options out there.
And since we don't have time to
get deeper, we just choose
here three great examples
to choose from.
And if you have a bit more time,
my colleague and great
mentor [INAUDIBLE]
did a great job in terms of
letting you know how all the
different MV* framework will
work in different use cases on
a Hello World of the MVC
framework, which
is the to-do list.
Why we do we need offline?
It's a question that's coming
again and again, and I would
just point out that I think the
best answer for that would
be faster is better, and it's
making your app much smoother,
much snappier.
Users will enjoy it
and appreciate it.
And of course, you get the
benefit that your app will
work perfectly when there's no
connection or when there is a
flaky connection.
In our demo later, we'll use
Lawnchair, which is a library
that lets us actually work in
an API that is above the
normal APIs that
HTML5 lets us.
And that's another benefit that
we wanted to show you,
because then later on if you
want to move from, let's say,
local storage or web storage
to IndexedDB,
it's very, very smoothly.
Other APIs that are under our
hands today, and actually in
our toolbox, it's of
course AppCache.
AppCache is letting you save
all the static information
that you need.
So first of all, and foremost,
it would be the HTML,
JavaScript and CSS file
that we need.
Usually it will be one
single-page app.
So it's one HTML file, and
then a bunch of CSS and
JavaScript, but also sound
files and images.
And then for saving our
persistent [? end ?] data, we
could use local storage,
which is a simple key
value API, or IndexedDB.
And today with HTML5 file
API, we could save
binary does as well.
So offline, we touch about it.
I think the main challenge with
offline is to write the
right sync layer.
Because to save the data, we'll
show you it's quite easy
and inefficient.
The sync is the most
problematic way.
How it will work best in your
use case, and how your user
will appreciate the fact, like
we saw in the demo today of
Google Docs, how easy is it to
just notify the user slightly.
They could still be productive,
they could still
work and write their manifesto,
but then when we
have the connection, we're doing
the right thing in terms
of syncing it immediately
to the cloud.
I choose here to show you with
one line of code we could
check exactly, what
is the status?
Do we have connection or not?
And based on that information,
we could
make the right decision.
Another great feature that
[? Paul Kelly and I ?]
work on is Web Intents.
Web Intents basically lets you
have the Intents system that
we saw in Android, and
have it on the web.
And that's, in my humble
opinion, going to change the
world of web apps, and we're
going to see more and more web
apps harnessing their users
with more functionality
without the pain on you, the
developers, to code it against
the vast majority of API that
we see on the web today.
Just imagine the power of
allowing your users to share
anything on their favorite
social networks.
I know that some of you are
thinking, OK Ido, you're
speaking about things 3,000 feet
above, but we have lots
of users that are still using
older browsers that don't have
all the capabilities
and features that
you are talking about.
And just to mention here,
because I know that some of
the guys are more through the
app engine side, and are
working in big organizations
and big enterprises,
organizations, for people that
still have older browsers
under their hands and heads,
they could use
Google Chrome Frame.
It doesn't need any
administrative rights, and
once you install it, you get
every six weeks the greatest
and latest of Chrome, meaning
security, speed, and
simplicity inside IE.
So CSS transition, WebGL, drag
and drop, all the great things
that you want to accomplish in
your web app are there, and
they will stay there.
All you need is one line of
code, one line of meta header,
like it is here.
Or even better, if you have
control of your server, just
change the HTTP header.
And you can choose and play
and tune it to your needs.
If you want just certain
versions of IE,
it will work perfectly.
Now any modern web app--
great web app-- needs
a very strong server.
I guess it's just the right time
to ask Brad what's new in
that kingdom.
BRAD ABRAMS: Absolutely,
thanks Ido.
When I talk to web developers,
most of them are very
interested in a lot of the
client-side functionality that
Ido just talked about.
Building rich, interactive
experiences on the client is
the way to sort of focus on your
users and make sure those
needs are met.
And so the last thing you want
to have to worry about is
complexities related
to the server.
You'd like to just have that
taken care for you, but we do
need server environments.
You have to serve the HTML,
CSS and JavaScript.
You, a lot of times, can offload
expensive computations
to the server and
do those there.
You can do sharing and
collaboration on the server.
But then there's a bunch of
problems that you have as a
web developer when you're
dealing with the server
environment.
Where are you going
to host that?
Are you going to maintain
your own machine images?
What if Linux has
a security hole?
Are you going to patch that?
Are you going to keep up with
all that infrastructure that
needs to be done?
And then specifically, when
you're talking about the new
sort of architecture, when using
an MVC pattern on the
client, communicating to the
server via rest APIs, well,
how are you going to do
that serialization?
How are you going to
do authentication?
How are you going to do the
things we call the OAuth dance
to get users' credentials
and permissions?
So as you might guess, I have an
answer for you, and that's
App Engine.
So App Engine's been around
for several years now.
It's a proven technology for
building web apps and these
modern web apps.
With App Engine, it's very easy
to build and manage and
run your applications.
You write code in Java or Python
or Go and upload it
into our data centers, and
Google runs it in our large
distributed data centers
all over the world.
Our SRE team keeps your
applications up.
Earlier today, we launched
Google Cloud Endpoints.
And Google Cloud Endpoints makes
it significantly easier
to build web APIs, to build
REST-based endpoints that you
expose from your App
Engine app and
consume that in clients.
So you can write your
application in App Engine,
expose these endpoints via
standard REST-based
interfaces.
We handle the serialization and
the authentication, and we
give you strongly typed clients
for Java, for Android,
Objective C, for iOS, and what
we'll be talking about here is
a modern JavaScript client
library that you can go use.
And what's great is that all
this technology that we're
using here with for cloud
endpoints is built on the same
technology.
It's the same stack that Google
uses to do billions of
transactions with our Google
APIs, like the Google+ APIs or
many of the other Google APIs
that are out there.
So you're using the exact
same infrastructure and
tools, as we'll see.
Ido and I were sort of
thinking about what--
I don't want to give it away.
We were thinking about what we
had in common, what sort of
demo we should do.
We thought the best way to
explain this to you would be
to do a demo.
So we thought about what we
would have in common, and we
thought what you in the audience
might appreciate.
So we sort of look at the
demographics of I/O, and we
came up with a plan.
And we decided we would
write an app to
rate and review beers.
So this is the Birra
sample application.
Actually, if it takes off,
you won't Ido and
I at I/O next year.
So we'll do our own little
start up for
beer rating and reviewing.
So it lets you enter beers
from all over the world.
You can review those beers,
you can comment on them.
And what we're going to for the
next, say, 45 minutes or
so is build out this application
right here in
front of you, so you can
see how it goes.
So let's make sure we
understand, before we get
started, the architecture
of this app.
So the beer application,
start with beer.
We're going to store the
beers, or at least the
metadata about the beers, in the
largest NoSQL data store
in production in the world,
and that's in App Engine's
NoSQL data store.
And then we're going to do some
application logic in App
Engine to do things like
sorting, filtering of those
beers, and we'll show you
about how that works.
And then we're going to expose
that over endpoints so that
there's a REST-based
interface for that.
And then Ido's going to consume
that in a modern
JavaScript client
using offline,
using the MVC framework.
OK so it sounds good?
Should we get started?
OK, so let's get started here.
I'm going to start by building
out the server side of the
application.
And what I have installed on
my Mac here is the standard
version of Eclipse, and then I
have the version of Google
Plug-in for Eclipse that just
shipped yesterday, so brand
new bits, and we're going to
use that to start out.
So I'll just say New
Application.
We're going to call
this Birra.
Anybody know why it's
called Birra?
AUDIENCE: It's Hebrew.
BRAD ABRAMS: Hebrew.
Hebrew for beer, yep.
And we're not to use GWT for
this, but we are going to use
App Engine.
And this will create a
scaffolding application for us
to have us get started.
And here it is.
Again, this is the server
side of the code.
And what we're going to
do is come in here
and add a new class.
And as I mentioned, whenever you
start with a beer review
class application, you've
gotta start with beer.
It's central to our application,
and it was
central to the development
of this demo as well.
So we have this beer class,
and this is a
plain old Java object.
Now we need to think, what
is the data about
beer we want to store?
So what do you want to
store about beer?
Any thoughts from the
audience here?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
BRAD ABRAMS: Oh, the
alcohol content.
That's good.
Alcohol content.
IDO GREEN: Maybe name.
BRAD ABRAMS: The name.
That's good.
AUDIENCE: Color.
BRAD ABRAMS: The color
of the beer.
That's pretty good.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
BRAD ABRAMS: OK, yeah, we need
a double for the price.
So I cheated, and ahead of time,
I had a version of the
beer that actually works
with the rest the demo.
But it is still a plain
old Java object.
So what I've defined is just
a set of properties that we
have, a set of regular fields,
and then just getters and
setters for that.
So there's nothing funny here.
Now what we need to do is teach
App Engine how to store
this object.
Right now, it's just a
plain Java object.
We need to teach App Engine how
to store that, and to do
that we're going to use the
old tried and true JDO.
It's been around forever,
but it's effective.
Everything I'm going to show
you, though, works with any
persistence layer you'd
like to use.
You can use cloud endpoints,
however you want.
This just happens to work
well for the tool.
So we've made it available
with JDO, and
now we have our object.
Now what we need to do is expose
this in a way that Ido
can consume from his client.
So to do that, we'll show off
our first new feature of this,
which is Generate Cloud
Endpoint Class.
So we'll click on that,
and hopefully--
yeah, there it goes--
we'll generate a beer
endpoints class.
And in this class, we have this
@API attribute on it.
The @API attribute indicates
that all the public methods on
this class will be exposed
as REST endpoints.
And we'll see how the URL for
that looks in a second.
And we can change the name of
that, which will show up on
the URL, to Birra,
so it matches.
And let's just take a brief
look at what we have here.
We have a method to list
all the beers that
are in the data store.
Now we've given you some
scaffolding code just to get
started with that.
And over the course of this
demo, we'll go through and
modify that.
And then when you write your
real apps later tonight, or
maybe next week, you'll be
modifying it even more.
So it basically just iterates
through the data store and
returns all the results.
Notice I don't have to deal with
any serialization logic
or authentication logic.
All of that is going
to be taken care of
for us by the framework.
Then, same thing, I can get a
particular beer by its ID.
That code is generated for us.
I can insert a beer.
And notice this is an
HTTP POST method.
For you people that are REST
heads, and you're kind of into
the REST pattern and making sure
that works, we've tried
to adhere to it nicely here, and
you'll see you have a lot
of control as we go through.
But one of the things we've done
is expose this as a POST
method because it's insert.
And then UPDATE is a put,
same sort of thing.
And then of course we have
this DELETE method here.
IDO GREEN: Remove.
BRAD ABRAMS: Remove, ah, yes.
IDO GREEN: I would really,
really encourage you to put it
as a DELETE, because it's not
only me, but the community
would love to have
DELETE here.
It will fit perfectly.
BRAD ABRAMS: Yes, so the problem
is this looks so nice
in my Java code, I don't want
to mess with my Java code.
But I want to change what it
looks like for him on the
JavaScript side.
And so what we have, I'm going
to introduce you to this
attribute we'll become
very familiar
with, the @API attribute.
And what it does is it gives us
a way to customize the REST
endpoint that's generated
from this method.
So in this case, I can change
the name to be beers.delete,
and that'll give us a nice
experience in the Java, IOS,
or in our case, JavaScript
client that this generates.
OK, so I think we have a
basic interface here.
Let's just do some
testing of it.
So I spun up the local
development time server, so
it's essentially a baby version
of App Engine running
on my laptop here.
And then what I'm going to do
is use every web developer's
favorite tool, Curl.
We're going to test this with
plain old Curl, just to make
sure everything is working
nicely before we
hand it off to Ido.
So the first thing you'll
notice, if you're an App
Engine geek, you'll notice that
_ah, that's the reserve
namespace in App Engine.
So none of the APIs you're
defining here will interfere
with the rest of your web
applications, because we've
put them in the reserve
namespace.
Then we put them in
APIs and Birra.
If you recall, Birra was the
attribute that I put on
earlier, was there.
And then the name of
the object is beer.
And we just do an HTTP get to
it, and it returns all the
beers in the data store,
which is none.
And notice that the return
is a nicely formatted
JSON object for us.
So let's look at what it would
take to add something to that.
So let me grab this Curl.
So we'll do HTTP post, and
put a new beer in here.
And the beer name will be Bud.
That's my brother's favorite
beer, so I'm trying not to
give him a hard time.
IDO GREEN: Be patient.
BRAD ABRAMS: Patient
with him, yes.
So what we've seen now is we did
a put, HTTP put, got that
beer in the database.
We got an ID for it, ID 1, and
of course all the other fields
are null, but we get a
well-formatted JSON object here.
Now what we can do is go back
and look, and the data story
isn't quite refreshed yet,
but there it is.
It returns as a list, and then
in true REST style, I can just
put a URL parameter passing the
beer ID, and of course,
there it is.
So no surprises there.
So that looks pretty good, I
think we're almost ready to
hand it off.
But I thought what I'd show
is a little bit more--
right before this talk, I went
and deployed one of these to
an endpoint.
And I just wanted to show you a
little bit about some of the
infrastructure that's
there for you.
So if you go to _ah API, and
then hit the discovery point,
for any of your App Engine apps
that are using endpoints,
we provide a discovery
endpoint for that.
And that discovery endpoint
gives you metadata about, in
this case, all of the APIs that
are available on that App
Engine app.
So we have two.
We have the discovery one, and
of course we ate our own dog
food and used cloud endpoints
to serve the discovery.
And then we have
our Birra one.
So let's take a look at Birra,
and we bring that up.
And if you look at this
endpoint, you'll see a full
description of all the types,
of all the methods and
operations that are
part of this.
So this is a handy tool to debug
and use, but it's also
what we use to create the
strongly typed client
libraries in all the different
languages.
In fact, as I mentioned, this
uses the same infrastructure
that the rest of Google's
APIs use.
And because we use that same
infrastructure, we're able to
use tools like API Explorer.
So if you do slash APIs
Explorer, it'll give you a
nice interactive view
of your API.
So those are all the
APIs, nicely named.
And then I can click on them,
and I can execute that API
right here from this interactive
experience right
in the browser, without having
to write a client.
So in this case, this App Engine
app has to spin up.
But there it is.
And you see a well-formatted get
request and exactly what
the response is supposed
to be.
So as Ido and I were building
out this application, we found
this invaluable tool
we could use.
Because I could deploy an
application, I could test it
independent of his client.
He could work.
When he built his client, he
could play with it, figure out
what exactly the payloads were
supposed to be, and it was
really nice.
It was also nice-- so we could
shift blame between us.
He would often claim it to be
a bug, and I would show that
it works nicely in Explorer,
so we knew
where to put the problem.
And it was equally the other
way, I'll mention.
OK, so that's the
basic Explorer.
I think we're ready for you to
start building our client.
IDO GREEN: Absolutely so as
we all know, in software
development we want to take
small steps and see that we
are on a good path.
So first, there's a very, very
simple, just plain vanilla
JavaScript example.
So as you can see here, I'm
having this URL, and as Brad
mentioned, on our new service,
I want a certain version.
And here, this simple AJAX, you
see, I just get a payload
of the list of beers.
Let's see how does it look.
Oops.
BRAD ABRAMS: Oh, did
I not switch you?
I'm sorry.
Failing on my Java already.
IDO GREEN: Let's see again,
how does it look?
Yeah, so we got the
list of beers.
What I said before, and you
couldn't see, this is the
simple endpoint that I'm
calling, and it's plain
vanilla JavaScript, so it's
simple AJAX code.
So as you can see and imagine,
you could consume it and walk
with it, and it's
good and simple.
However, we have another, even
better thing, and that's
Google API JavaScript library,
which actually takes some of
the load and gives you a better
API to work with when
you're working in the client.
And here all we need to do, as
you can see, is put the script
tag and load it asynchronously,
and of course
giving it a call back, so when
it will be loaded, it will run
our case of load API.
We could set client ID, API
ID, et cetera, and load
several APIs.
In our case, we'll keep it
simple, but you can imagine
how you could extend
it and build a big
application with it.
When we're getting the beers, we
have this nice API, and if
you remember before, when Brad
was making those little
changes that make our life
easier and more readable, here
we're just calling the
exact same endpoints.
And we're getting the
same results.
Now, we've built this small test
page just so you'll have
a sense of how the code
looks like, and you
can play with it.
I will just mention that all the
code and all the examples
that we're showing you are on
GitHub, and we'll put the
links after the talk so you
could take it, fork it, work
with it, and join our startup
later, right?
So just feel free, if we're
running really fast on
examples, you'll be able to tap
into them later and just
work with them more
thoroughly.
So let's see the example of
just showing the list of
beers, so let's work
here as well.
The code of it is extremely
simple.
As we saw before, we we're just
running this entry point,
and we're showing the
list of beer.
Let's see how we could--
What we're doing when we're
saving, when we're adding a
new beer, Basically it's just
boilerplate code to fetch the
information from the dialog
that will pop up
and call the insert.
In our case, we know it's an
insert when we don't have any
beer ID, because we want the
server to make a unique ID for
each and every beer.
If we got a beer ID, we're just
calling it an update.
Let's see how does it look like
on the amazing test page
that we did.
We'll close it so we'll have
a bit of real estate.
Let's try to add the new beer,
maybe because I have a good
friend from Australia.
And another nice functionality
that we'll look at in the code
in a second is the ability to
take the little image here and
just drag and drop it.
And of course you can see the
geo information that we just
got the information
from our browser.
Let's save it.
We got the confirmation.
Now we could take this just to
make sure it's been saved in
our production.
And sure enough, it is.
And of course, we
could remove it.
We're getting the answer that is
was removed, and now if we
try to fetch it, we're
getting nothing.
So we saw, basically, the crude
operations that any app
will have to deal with.
It's very, very simple and
very easy to achieve.
I will just show you
real quick how.
So we saw the insert, we saw the
update, and this is what
we're doing when we get
the response back.
We'll get the response back in
a JSON format, so if we'll
have arrows, we'll know how to
handle them and notify the
user what we need to
do in that case.
I think that we have the basic
operations, but with all these
social movements, maybe we'll
let our friends have some
comments on the Birra ranking.
BRAD ABRAMS: Yes, comments.
Awesome.
You know, client guys always
want more features.
Have you noticed that?
IDO GREEN: Trying.
BRAD ABRAMS: OK, I'm up.
So let's go through and
see how you would add
comments to this app.
So we've got beers.
I think we should start with
comments exactly where we did
with beers.
We'll just add a new class
called comment, and then it's
the same story we saw before.
We'll go ahead and define a
plain old Java object and then
annotate it with the
JDO attributes.
And here I just have an ID for
this, the user that made the
comment, when they made it,
the comment itself.
And I'm using the beer ID.
So this is effectively
a foreign key.
It's which beer is
this comment for?
And we'll look at that
a little bit later.
OK, so I take this comment,
and I do the same thing.
I generate a cloud
endpoint for it.
So we're going to expose the
same sort of rest interface
here for comments.
So there it is.
And now we're going to change
the name of that to be Birra
so that these sort of are merged
into the same API.
And now, when we look at this
list comments method, well
it's going to list all the
comments in the data store.
But that may not be
what Ido wants.
Ido's probably going to
want a comment for a
particular beer ID, right?
So what we probably want to do
is pass in a beer ID here and
have that beer ID return
the comments only
associated with that.
But we have to figure out how
to make that work for us in
the REST world.
So again, our API method
attribute is
going to be our friend.
So let me just import that
and grab this code.
So what we're going to do here
is we change list comments to
have a parameter
called beer ID.
And notice we customize
the path here.
So I imagine a few of you saw
the path earlier and thought,
oh, no, I hope they're not auto
generating that path.
You have a lot of control over
exactly what the REST
interface looks like, so you can
make it look like the way
you need to.
So in this case, I thought it
made more sense to put the
comments logically
underneath beers.
So beers, the beer ID, and
then show me all the
comments for that.
So that's what I've modeled
for you there.
So we've done that for list.
And then, of course, we need to
change the data store code.
So luckily it's very easy.
We just say beer ID equals and
then the beer ID, and that
will do the filtering for us.
You could imagine lots more rich
logic you could do here.
We need to do a similar thing
for get, so let's go
ahead and do that.
And notice here we're passing
beer ID and the
ID on the REST call.
And then we need to do something
for insert as well.
And then I'll leave the others
to do offline, but there's
just a few just to show you
what it looks like.
So now we'll run it in the debug
server, and we'll take a
look at how we test this.
So I will test it in Curl
as we saw before.
Go ahead and try that, and
again, the data store has to
spin up, so it takes
just a second.
OK, so there are no items,
no comments.
That's what we expected.
And then what I'm going to do
now is add a new comment here
for that beer.
And then we can go back and look
at comments for beer one
and see if there's
any comments.
And there, there is.
And then again in the
REST style I can
do for comment two.
So that looks pretty
good, Ido.
I think you're ready
add comments.
IDO GREEN: Oh yeah, beautiful.
So first, let's see how it looks
when we're trying just
to add a simple comment to a
beer for I/O. And then we're
doing a simple get.
We see all the comments
that we had.
Let's look at the simple
code that does it.
So basically, you could see here
when I'm clicking on the
Save button of the dialog that
I just showed you, I'm
gathering some information from
the user, and I'm getting
some information behind the
scene, like in the case of the
beers, I got the geolocation
here.
I just want to take the exact
time that the user entered,
and you could think about
lots of other use cases.
And then I'm just calling
the endpoint.
Before that, I'm making sure
that I have some nice spinner
to show the users that some
work is being done.
And I'm inserting the beer into
the App Engine, and when
I'm returning the call, I'll
just show, in case of an
error, some alert.
And if everything is
fine, I'm just
showing the list of comments.
So we have comments,
and it's pretty
straightforward, of the beers.
All the heavy handling has been
done for us for free in
the server side.
One thing that I want to show
you, we spoke about offline
capabilities.
How easy is it to achieve,
today, an offline capability
in terms of doing the initial
loading of, let's say, the top
15 beers, and saving them
locally in our browser?
So you can see here that when
I'm loading the API, I had
this commented.
Now I've uncommented it.
Let's try and go over
it real quickly.
Basically, I'm getting
a payload of data,
of items, of beers.
And I'm going on each and every
one of them, and I'm
calling this object that
I defined Birra.db.
What it basically does, it's
extending Lawnchair and giving
us the basic operation that you
will expect any layer, any
DB layer to do.
In our case, it saves beer.
Let's try now to run this
code from scratch.
We'll open the Dev Tools just
to see what's going on,
because there are some really
nice capabilities in Dev Tools
that let you see what's going
on with your app.
Let's load it again.
OK, we've got the beers.
Now what you could do in Dev
Tools, which is pretty cool,
is go to Resources.
And in Resources, you can go to
Local Host, and basically
you can see here that I got all
the beers with the keys.
And Lawnchair actually did the
extra work for me and made
sure that I'll have
indexes here.
So if I want to fetch
a range of beers, it
will be quite quickly.
Another nice thing that you
could see here is that I'm
having a global beer ID in
my test page, and that's
something really useful when
you're doing-- because even
when I'm loading and I'm
wanting to work with a
specific beer, I could do it
quite efficiently, and I don't
need to remember what was the
last ID that I worked with.
So we have the offline
capabilities.
The sync layer will be in the
GitHub repository, so you
could check it out later.
And let's have a quick look
about how the simple code of
Lawnchair looks like.
Basically, we're extending it,
giving it to our own name.
And now you can see that, for
instance, saving, all we need
to do is take the object,
stringify it, because local
search will work with key
value of strings.
And then just run it, and have
in the call back the response
that everything is OK.
If not, of course, we need
to inform it to the user.
What we did with that is that
you all know that the best
practices of software
development told us to have
continuous integration
and unit testing.
And I want to show you a small
example of how we did it in
our small use case of saving
locally the beers.
We created a [? Qedit ?]
page.
It is done for you.
It's letting us know that for
each and every change that
we're doing, which tests are
passing and which are failing.
You'll have it in the GitHub
repository to look at it
later, more thoroughly, but it's
just one of those things
that, up to now, we didn't have
on the client, and now we
could run with all the best
practices on the client, as
well as on the server.
We have offline capabilities.
We spoke about syncing.
In that example I gave-- and I
spoke about 15, 20 beers--
I have a good friend that
drinks quite a bit.
I think if we'll have maybe
pagination, it will be--
BRAD ABRAMS: Yes.
Yes.
See again, these client guys
with their features.
Yeah, so what I showed you
before with the beers.
So we're back on the
server, looking at
the list beers method.
It returns all the beers
in our data store.
Well that might work fine for
this demo, but we're going to
have a wildly successful
startup, right?
So we're going to have hundreds,
thousands, millions
of beers in data store.
So we want to support
paging of that.
And to do that, I also want to
show you a few of the other
cool capabilities
of endpoints.
So what I've done is, off stage,
while Ido was working
there, I wrote this
list beers method.
I updated it a little bit.
And I added a couple of
nullable parameters.
So in endpoints, nullable
parameters are optional, so
you don't have to
pass those in.
And so they show up as query
string parameters on the URL,
so anything you mark
nullable will be a
query string parameter.
You can have any combination
of nullable and required as
you'd like.
So in this case, I'm going to
take two nullable parameters.
One is going to be the limit.
That is, how many beers do you
want to return at this time?
And the other is the cursor
string, or the cursor.
That is, where were you
last time you asked?
So the first time, obviously
you don't pass
anything in for that.
The second time, you pass
in the result I
passed you last time.
And so luckily for us, App
Engine's data store has some
very nice support for that,
which we'll see.
So that's the declaration.
And then you can see if they
pass in a cursor string, then
we go ahead and set
that in the query.
We set the cursor
they passed in.
If they passed in a limit,
we set that as a range.
And then what we do is we go
ahead and do our execute and
get all the results back
from data store.
And then we save
off the cursor.
So wherever you were, give
me a cursor for that.
And then we get a web save
string, so that's effectively
a base 64 encoded string that's
unique for where this
user was, so that you can pass
it back at any time and get
back the next set of results.
So that's really
handy to have.
And then what we do is we return
that, and notice we're
returning a complex
object this time.
We're returning all of those
elements as we were before,
but we're also returning
that cursor string.
Yep, so we go ahead
and save that.
We want to run this in our local
development time server.
And then to do a test of paging,
we need to go ahead
and add a couple of items
to our data store.
So I'll add Mom's Home Brew and
Bob's Indian Pale Ale so
you can see all those
are there.
And then let's look at all the
items in our data store.
OK, so there we go.
That's two of them, so
that's pretty good.
Maybe it'll wake
up in a second.
OK, so [? great. ?]
We have all three of them.
We have ID 1, ID 3, and ID 4.
For those playing at home,
where was ID 2?
Where was ID 2?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
BRAD ABRAMS: No, it was the
comment that we did.
The comment we put in.
Anyway, OK.
Data store trivia for you.
OK, so there's all those, and
now let's test out limit.
So we'll do that.
We'll pass a query string
parameter for limit, and you
see we just use the
query string.
And notice now we're getting
this next page token.
That tells us what to pass in
to get the next one, and I
have already got one of those as
well, just to save you from
watching me try to type that.
And so we pass in the limit and
the cursor string, and we
get the next one.
So Ido, you want to add paging
to the app there?
IDO GREEN: Yeah, it's
looking good.
The client life is good.
Now all we need to do is
to take these two extra
parameters that Brad just
mentioned, limit and cursor,
and just use them.
So if you remember at the
beginning when I was calling
this endpoint, I was calling
just list with none of the
parameters.
Now I'll use both of them.
And basically what we'll
do, we'll save the
cursor as our pointer.
And if we want, we'll know to
call it later and just make
sure that we're fetching the
extra amount of beers.
Let's see how it looks like.
Let's try to fetch one by one.
So we're getting the beer, and
then we get the button More,
because we know that now we've
got the cursor back, the next
token, and if we click, you see
here that it's Bud, it's
[? VB Gold, ?]
and we have more and more.
So pagination is working
quite perfectly.
What I'm thinking is that, after
all, we are a search
company, and maybe we'll
have search in our app.
BRAD ABRAMS: Search, search.
Do you see these features?
Yes, let's switch over
and see how we would
add search to this.
And in the process, we'll learn
more about cloud endpoints.
So App Engine, as you might be
aware, recently launched
support for search.
It actually uses some of the
same underlying infrastructure
that we use for Google search.
And so if you've studied the
search problem, the way search
starts is with an index.
So we want to create an index of
all the items that we want
searchable.
So here's the basic code
to do that index.
And we're going to call
it beerindex.
We can set some constraints on
it that controls how fast
queries go based
on consistency,
guarantees, and whatnot.
But we've done that
initialization.
Now what we need to do is
populate our index.
So what we'll do is add a new
method here, and we want to
customize what goes
in the index.
For example, we may not want to
put the image in the index.
That'll just bloat
up our index.
So we want to have a little bit
of customization, which I
have written for you
ahead of time.
So there we are.
This is an add to search index
method, and what we're doing
is just creating a new
search document.
We're Google, so everything's
a document, even if you're
talking about beers.
So we add a document,
and we set its name.
And notice we're just pulling
these properties right out of
the beer objects.
And notice sometimes, like
name, we're using text.
And other times, when
we do score, we're
setting it as a number.
So we're actually telling our
search index which things are
text, which things
are numbers.
And that's going to give
us some strong query
capabilities, which we'll
see in just a minute.
OK, so that's that
basic thing.
Now all we need to do is
actually add the beers to the
data store.
So we need to call
this method.
So let's start up
here at the top.
Let's see, list is fine,
get is fine.
Insert, when they add a new
item to the data store, we
need to go ahead and add that
to our search index.
Update, when they update that
beer, we're just going to add
it to the data store, and as
long as the IDs match--
we need to add it
to our index--
and as long as the IDs
match, we'll be OK.
It'll update.
So that way our index will stay
fresh, and then in remove
we had a bug earlier that Ido
so skillfully found at the
last minute.
And in remove we need to go
ahead and make sure we remove
that beer from our
index as well.
So that's that basic thing.
I think we're ready to test
that, so I'll just spin up the
development time server again
as our pattern is,
and then do a search.
So we actually need to add a new
beer to the data store so
that it actually gets indexed.
And notice when I add this, look
down here at the bottom
of the console, you'll see the
search engine actually spin up
because now we're adding it to
an index, so we have to have
that service up and
running as well.
So that search started, so
hopefully that means we should
be able to query for
this and find it.
Oh, actually, we can't query
for it because I didn't add
the query method.
Let's go back.
The whole point of that bit was
to add this search method,
to show you doing custom
methods in endpoints.
So we'll add this, and notice
this is a list method that's
similar, but we're exposing
it as an HTTP get.
So you get to customize the
verb, just like you get to
customize the path.
We pass in a required argument
for the query string, and then
all we're doing, really, is
passing that query string to
our search index.
The search results come back.
And we pull out the index from
the search results and call
that getBeer method that we
defined before, that will call
data store, get our beer.
And then we return the
whole list of those.
OK, so with that we should
be able to--
so we've added that item
to the data store.
Now we need to search for it.
So we'll search for that cool
beer, and search engine will
start again.
Oh, yeah.
OK, tell you what.
Because I had to start and
re-stop, let's skip
ahead to this part.
So we added a couple of
different beers with score ID
11, with a score of 9, so with
various different scores.
And I'll show you searching
for those.
So notice that the search can
be pretty powerful here.
We can say the score
equals something.
So we actually can
do math here.
So I could actually say where
the score is less than this.
So you see this, coupled with
the fact that it actually does
Boolean operators as well, gives
you some really powerful
query capability for
the service.
So with this done, Ido, I think
we're ready for you to
take it off.
IDO GREEN: Perfect.
Excellent.
So they say that simplicity is
the ultimate sophistication.
And I think in that case, you
must agree with me that it's
pretty simple, that
piece of code that
we have in the client.
Basically what we're doing here,
you can all see it good?
I could make it larger.
You see it well?
Maybe even larger.
Basically, we're listening
to the keydown event.
In our case, we want to catch
the Enter when the user is
finishing to click
the term in.
And then we're just taking the
payload, the search term,
passing it to the search
endpoint, and let's see what's
going on here when we are
doing it for real.
So you saw here that
I just put a break
point in Dev Tools.
That allows it to now inspect
and see what's going on and
what we got back from
the server.
If you hover, you'll see that
we got an array of items.
We could dive into them, see
exactly what's going on.
And when we are happy, we could
just release it and see
that we got the list of
beers that we wanted.
As Brad mentioned, it's much
more powerful than just that.
You could do things like that,
and then let's leave it so we
could run properly, and get all
the beers that are from
score 3 and above.
We could do even better than
that and go and play with some
geo queries, like this one,
which basically will give us a
view of beers around us, so
around the user of our app.
Here I cheated a bit, and I just
gave a map that mimics
what the functionality
will be like.
But you can how easy it is to
use the search from the client
and get some sophisticated
queries that you don't need to
code anything in order to
achieve them, and slice and
dice the data that you have in
your app in some clever ways,
thanks to the search
capabilities.
Now I don't know, I have a few
more requests, but I think
it's maybe time for
production.
Maybe we could deploy it.
BRAD ABRAMS: OK, ready to
deploy to production.
OK, great.
So it's very easy to do this.
We have a set of command line
tools and stuff so you can
script them.
But as a developer, it's nice
that right from Eclipse, you
can go ahead and deploy this.
So while Ido was talking, I went
and set the application
ID for this.
So if you just go to
appengine.com, everybody can
get 10 free apps that have a
pretty generous free quota,
and it's free and always
free for that tier.
So you can go get your ID.
I got Birra I/O 2012.
And then you just
click Deploy.
And what's going to happen
now is it packages your
application locally and sends
it up to the server for
deployment.
And this only takes a max of
two or three minutes over
normal Wi-Fi.
Let's let that go.
IDO GREEN: Maybe I'll just
show them the Web
Intents that I forgot.
BRAD ABRAMS: Oh, sure,
you want to
switch back to Web Intents?
OK.
And by then, this
will be done.
IDO GREEN: I'm really passionate
about this small
operation, and I just wanted to
show you how easy it is to
hook it up to your apps.
So basically with Web Intent,
we're letting the user choose
how they want to achieve
an intent in action.
In our case, let's try
and share our beer.
So as you can see here, from
Chrome 19 and above it's
natively in the browser.
When I'm clicking Share Beer,
I'm getting a few options here
that I found myself using a lot,
but you could add, and
there's plenty more
in the Chrome Web
Store to check around.
And in my case, let's
see how it's done.
I just want to send
it through Gmail.
So you can see the payload, in
my case, it's just the beer
name, the score, and maybe some
link back to the app.
Very simple.
And the power of it is that,
check this set of lines that
makes our life so much easier.
So we're gathering in beer
details there, payload that we
want to send the intent.
Then we're constructing a new
intent, and it could be share,
it could be edit a photo.
So let's say that you want to
let your users edit a photo.
You don't need to code this
again and again and
reinvent the wheel.
You could use other services out
there that are focusing on
doing this work and excel in
it, and just let the users
talk to them.
And then we passing
the beer details.
And when we're starting the
window.navigator object, we're
passing the intent, starting the
activity, and the user is
taking it from there.
Very simple, very smooth, and of
course, we have JavaScript
chains to all the
other browsers.
So in Chrome, it's
coming natively.
In other browsers, the user
could achieve it with the
JavaScript chains
that we have.
BRAD ABRAMS: All right.
Awesome.
So that gave me plenty of time
to deploy the application to
production, just to give you a
sense of what it does, some
client-side stuff.
It uploads all the files and
then verifies that it's
available, updates all the
index, and it's deployed.
So as soon as it's deployed, the
next thing we wanted to do
is actually go do some
scalability--
IDO GREEN: Whoa, don't
do it yet.
BRAD ABRAMS: Well, whatever.
What we wanted to do is do some
scalability testing of it.
So we used ApacheBench, and this
is just very basic, off
the cuff scalability to give you
a sense of how this works.
ApacheBench is a widely
used open source
tool for doing this.
So we did 9,000.
This was on my laptop on our
Wi-Fi network at work, so we
did 9,000 connections,
100 at a time.
And you see the results we
got in percentile here.
So 90% of the requests
came back in
less than half a second.
IDO GREEN: It's not showing.
BRAD ABRAMS: Oh, it's not?
I'm sorry.
Great, thank you.
So now you see that we
used ApacheBench.
We got 90% of the requests came
back in half a second.
So that's pretty decent.
That's pretty good for a sort
of in-the-wild deployment.
And again, we didn't have to
do anything to make our app
actually scale that way.
So the next thing to do, I don't
know if you caught in
the keynote, we launched a new
sister project to App Engine.
Does anybody remember
what that's called?
Compute Engine?
I don't know if anybody
knows anything
about our data centers.
One of the things Google does
pretty well with the data
centers is networking logic.
So I thought it would be fun to
get a Compute Engine into
this and just see how quick that
would be to hit the App
Engine app from a Compute
Engine instance.
It turns out they're actually
in different data centers.
The App Engine app was running
in one data center, and the
Compute Engine was running
in another one.
But anyway, it's fun,
nonetheless, to see that 95%
of the requests came back in
less than seven milliseconds.
So it's actually pretty fast.
So if you're doing something,
you want to access your App
Engine app quickly, this
is the way to do it.
IDO GREEN: Rank a
lot of beers.
BRAD ABRAMS: It turns out that
the way this actually works
with App Engine is a lot of this
is static content coming
from the HTML app, and that
gets stored in Google's
distributed cache.
So it turns out it wasn't
actually hitting my App Engine
app at all.
It hits it one time to get the
HTML, and then after that, it
serves it out of the cache,
and those caches are
distributed globally.
And that's available for
all App Engine Apps.
You sort of get that for free.
So once we've figured that out,
we were actually playing
around with this, with different
arguments, had a
couple of machines playing
around with it just to see
sort of where we could get
the queries per second.
Have you seen the App
Engine graphs?
Like how many simultaneous
requests could we get?
We got a little crazy with the
ApacheBench tool, and we got
to 6,000 QPS just
playing around
with a couple of machines.
So that's pretty good, and
it's literally the
code you saw today.
Again, a lot of the QPS is
actually hitting the HTML
page, but it's really nice to
be able to know that you're
working on infrastructure that
you can just play around with
and get to 6,000 QPS.
To give you an idea, 6,000 QPS
is like a quarter of a million
requests a minute.
So what is that, maybe
a few hundred
thousand concurrent users?
So just think about if you're
going to stand up your own
machine to go serve 100,000
concurrent users, that might
take you a little while.
You might have to think about
some sharding and whatever,
and we've done all that work
for you with App Engine.
IDO GREEN: So main take aways.
I think we saw that it's pretty
nice today to be a
developer in terms of the
development experience.
With Google App Engine, you can
leverage and tap into the
infrastructure and write your
own RESTful APIs quite easily.
One of the nice things is that
not only do you not need to
think about scalability, you
could focus really on the API.
The API is, in most of the
cases, the most challenging
aspect of the system itself.
So now you could just devote the
vast majority of your time
to that critical section, and
of course, code it from the
client side with all the best
practices of HTML5 and the
newest APIs that are
under your hands.
And I think we mentioned a few
very important points that I
would ask people just to keep in
mind when they're building
their next modern web apps,
mobile or desktop.
One of the most important
features is, of course, the 60
frames per second and the
smoothness, and that's coming
with the option to make
the app work offline.
And lots of users and lots of
great apps like the Financial
Times, the New York Times,
Google Docs, Gmail, and so on
are enjoying it today.
And in the near future, we'll
see more and more users
expecting it.
So that's something
to keep in mind.
Web Intents, we showed you.
You have no excuse
not to use it.
It's so simple and trivial.
And I would really like to thank
you for coming to hear
us after the heavy lunch
that we had.
Both Brad and I will be in the
Sandbox if anyone has more
questions after we
have, of course,
the section for questions.
And as I mentioned before, you
could have all the source code
of all the examples, just to
play with them and see exactly
how it's working for you in
this GitHub repository.
We'll put the slides once--
BRAD ABRAMS: Oh, goodness.
I'm sorry.
You guys gotta help
me with this.
IDO GREEN: Yeah.
So you have the link to
the GitHub repository.
The code is actually there.
We'll have all the slides
and the other
documentation below it.
And of course, you could try
and test the app itself and
the endpoint itself
in birra-io2012.
Hit it as hard as you want.
We would love to see some
nice graphs on it.
And of course, check out
the new Endpoint API.
It's pretty powerful.
If, by any chance, you didn't
reach to Brad or myself after
the talk or in the Sandbox,
please feel
free to use our G+.
We both would be happy to answer
any questions that you
might have, or challenges or
problems that you might have
in the near future.
So thank you very much, and if
we have questions, we'd be
happy to take them.
BRAD ABRAMS: If you enjoyed the
show, we'd love for you to
vote with your little +1s.
Ido and I are always looking to
get better, so if you have
comments, there's the
URL on the back.
IDO GREEN: Absolutely.
BRAD ABRAMS: Thank
you very much.
IDO GREEN: Thank you.
BRAD ABRAMS: Should we just
do questions here?
Any questions?
IDO GREEN: If you ask
an easy question,
you're getting a sticker.
If it's a hard one,
no sticker.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering if
there's any plans on bringing
client-side adaptive images
into App Engine?
IDO GREEN: Do you
want to take it?
BRAD ABRAMS: What do you mean
by adaptive images?
AUDIENCE: Serving up different
resolutions for the multitude
of devices we have.
BRAD ABRAMS: Yep.
Yep.
We have heard that.
There's nothing that I have
right now for you.
IDO GREEN: What you can
use today is just--
you need to do the leg work,
but we have, of course, the
API to use it, but you need
to do the leg work for it.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thanks.
IDO GREEN: And now you
could get a sticker.
BRAD ABRAMS: Yes.
Please.
IDO GREEN: It wasn't hard.
Yes, please?
AUDIENCE: Do you guys have any
best practice recommendations?
I saw you get bit by it a few
times where when you're in an
application going page by page,
wizardy style things,
you have to wait until the
data store has your data
before you can then re-query
it back in page two.
And like you said, oh,
it's not there yet.
You have to wait a second
and try it again.
When you're in an application,
is there a better way or a
notifying way to then be told
my data's there, now I can
move forward?
IDO GREEN: Yeah, absolutely.
And actually, that's one of the
benefits of building your
app from the ground up
with offlink in mind.
Because then you'll know that
you have the most common data
that the user is using, and
you could make a nice
heuristic about what you will
want next and just fetch it
immediately from the
local storage.
And that's actually why we see
lots of apps that are really
snappy and really fast, because
they don't need to do
the round trip to the server and
fetch the information in
order to show it.
They already have it locally.
AUDIENCE: So you're saying that
you just keep it locally
and don't actually put it in
the data store until later?
IDO GREEN: Yeah.
So do everything locally first,
and then sync it when
you have time for it.
And when you have the right
connection, the right
bandwidth--
I saw some modern web apps
actually checking how good the
connection is.
There are a few JavaScript
libraries that let you do that
and then doing the syncing
just in the right time.
So that's one thing.
The other thing is that with
Google JavaScript API library,
you could tap and do
batch requests.
So you, using a leveraging one
connection with multiple
requests on top of it,
and that's of course
working much better.
You can have a sticker.
It was hard, but we made it.
AUDIENCE: How do you handle
security and privacy, in
particular, like in a health
care setting, if you're
writing a health care app,
keeping with regulations and
all that sort of stuff?
IDO GREEN: That's a great
question, so you'll definitely
get a sticker.
We haven't shown it, because
we didn't have time, but
authentication is coming
out of the box.
So it's perfect, and the
question is actually amazingly
good, because in other cases you
need to work pretty hard
to make your app secure.
And in our case, both the
endpoint is supporting the
cross-region sharing resources
and authentication
just out of the box.
So we'll have in the code,
actually, in GitHub, and you
could see how easy it is to
have, let's say, authenticated
comments or beers.
So only users that are
authenticated could actually
work with the app.
So in terms of security, you're
getting quite nice
things that have already
been done for you.
So you don't need to work
for them yourself.
BRAD ABRAMS: I can show
you an example.
AUDIENCE: So behind the scenes,
is Google indexing
patient data or whatever
information I'm storing?
BRAD ABRAMS: No.
No.
Let me do this one.
It's very clear in the App
Engine terms of service, we
can't even see the data that
you're putting in App Engine.
The only thing we can do with
the data that you're putting
in App Engine is serve
it back to you.
So we're not indexing
it in any way.
It is completely your data.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thanks.
IDO GREEN: Sure.
BRAD ABRAMS:OK, one
more, probably.
Yeah.
You get to be the
last question.
AUDIENCE: Right on.
Hopefully it's an easy one,
and I'll get a sticker.
IDO GREEN: I hope so
AUDIENCE: Web sockets
on App Engine.
When is that gonna
be available?
BRAD ABRAMS: Stay tuned.
IDO GREEN: I'm holding
my fingers as well.
BRAD ABRAMS: Nothing's
due out right now.
That was so easy.
AUDIENCE: That was
a short one.
There are a few annotation
APIs like JAX-RS or
something like that.
I wanted to ask you what is @API
method, and what about
existing standards?
BRAD ABRAMS: So we
discussed this.
We decided @API, @API methods
are ones that we created for
our cloud endpoint, because
there's a lot of things that's
very custom to that.
We definitely think it's
possible to layer on top of
that a standards-based
approach.
If somebody's interested in
doing an open source project
around that or what not, I'd
be happy to discuss some of
the details with you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
IDO GREEN: Thank
you very much.
BRAD ABRAMS: Cool.
Great.
Thank you, guys.